[inaudible]
Kuwait's is alone with guitar,
the only country in the Arabian
peninsula where elections are hells.
Yep.
You heard that right?
Many of you might know this country
because of the oil reserves that wealth,
all the facts that they were invaded by
Saddam Hussein in the 90s but Kuwait is
much more than that.
It is one of the most tolerant nations
in the Islamic world's women can vote.
They can run for office and they even
have a female
paint
lots and all of these apps.
For decades,
the Kuwaiti royal family has been
America's best friends in the Gulf.
This is why when they were invaded in
1990 uncle Sam didn't hesitate for a
moment and sent in their troops
immediately.
This will not stand.
This will not stand this aggression
against a Kuwait.
Now you might wonder,
why are we talking today about Kuwait?
Well,
this is the only Arab country alongside
a man that hasn't joined the diplomatic
of block of Qatar.
Yeah.
Saudi Arabia,
Bahrain,
Egypt,
and the United Arab Emirates broke off
relations with Qatar in the worst
diplomatic crisis to hit the Gulf Arab
states in decades.
The three Gulf countries and Egypt
accused Qatar of supporting terrorism
and destabilizing the region and now the
big question is why is Kuwait is not on
this list of nations who have cut ties
with Qatar?
What kind of interest and does this
country have in this diplomatic crisis?
How does that been?
This has to work well today.
We are going to answer these questions
before we do.
Let's get to know a bit more about this
particular part of the planet.
Ooh,
in the Persian Gulf,
the first country we need to know about
in the Arabian peninsula is Saudi
Arabia.
Saudi Arabia is the biggest country in
the region,
both in terms of population and
territory,
but it is not the only
country.
Yeah,
yeah.
We have for United Arab Emirates,
which Dubai and Abu Dhabi are a part of.
This country has its own government,
its own laws and its own currency and
this absolutely independent from the
Saudis.
The same goes for Qatar,
which has its own foreign policy and
holds better public relations with
enemies of the Saudis like the Islamic
Republic of Iran.
And now you might be thinking that all
of these countries have one important
thing in common.
The fact that they are all incredibly
oil rich,
right?
Well,
actually that's pretty wrong.
Here we have the Republic of Yemen,
a country that is extremely poor.
Now of course it will if these countries
have a common history,
common traditions as well as religion,
but make no mistake,
each of them have their own
peculiarities.
For example,
the United Arab Emirates was the first
country who realized oil is not forever
and therefore they decided to diversify
their economy,
so they accrued,
represents just 3% of the total economy
of Cuba is also a totally different
animal.
Yes,
they have a monarchy,
the so called apnea,
but he is controlled buying eight
constitution.
The parliament.
Well,
hold on for just a second because this
doesn't mean they are a 100% democratic
country.
In fact,
their system,
it's way more complicated than that.
So,
well that's,
I'm looking at it now.
Yeah.
Does semi democracy work in Kuwait?
Kuwait is known as a semi democracy.
I'm like Saudi Arabia.
Kuwait has a freedom of religion.
This is why you can even find a catholic
church in the middle of Kuwait
City.
Things like the hit job on north
mandatory and even the laws regarding
alcohol.
Beth fairly liberal in comparison with
their neighbors.
Of course it's still forbidden.
Nz buy and sell alcohol,
but it is legal to drink in privates.
Nonetheless,
the main peculiarity about Kuwait are
their elections.
All the adult natural born citizens have
the right to vote their parliament every
four years.
This includes women in these elections.
Political parties are
a bit,
doesn't it
mean candidates have no ideology at all?
They can also campaign freely and have
debates.
Needless to say,
the political debate here is totally
different compared to that in the UK or
the u s yeah,
the political spectrum is not only a
right wing or left wing kind of thing.
Of course some kinds of ads are highly
conservative and others are more liberal
and open.
Z Western culture
sure
is not the only thing that divides
Kuwaiti society.
There is also this never ending fights
between Sunni Muslims and Shia Muslims.
This is because,
as I said before,
that is freedom of religion and that
means the creed of the candidates is as
important as his tax plan.
There's Mazzoni.
That bear is a nother big divide between
the so called urban voters am's,
the so called tribal once.
Just think about it for a moment.
This is a country with a long nomadic
tradition with half of the population
still living in tribes and these tribes
that own primaries to choose that own
candles.
Well said.
Elections are used to choose a national
assembly with the power to make laws and
even put a veto on the policies taken by
the executive branch.
But now you might be wondering how old
are the trees,
the prime minister,
all they voted for by mds as they do a
European countries or do they hold
presidential elections like they do in
the US?
Sorry.
Well
it's actually nothing like either of
those.
As I said,
Kuwait is a semiotic democracy.
This means that the head of state is the
Amea and he chooses the prime minister
and his,
so maybe this sounds like those
European.
Absolutely.
Monica is that you studied about in
history lessons?
Well,
it's not really exactly like that.
In fact,
in Arab monarchies,
the position of India is not inherited.
This is why in Saudi Arabia they have
big internal battles to choose their
leaders and as I explained in a previous
video,
royal families in this part of the wells
can have thousands of members.
Yes.
So in the case of Kuwait,
the members of the royal family,
the so called Al Subar House can vote
for the EMEA,
but right after the national assembly it
has to vote on whether they can accept
this decision or not.
But it's a hold on now for just a second
because just in case the system wasn't
complicated enough.
Here is another extra fact.
The constitution allows the air to
dissolve the parliaments many time he
wants fans.
Well that's something he does pretty
often.
Amir
of Kuwait dissolves parliament.
The move announced on state media after
an emergency government meeting sets the
stage for early elections.
And believe me,
parliamentary debates in Kuwait are far
from being quiet.
Emergency meetings are a common thing
and sometimes it's really hard to get
any kind of consensus.
For some analysts.
This is one of the reasons that explains
this.
The halakha economy,
we all know oil rich countries have so
much money they can spend as if there
was no tomorrow,
most natural born Qac citizens work on
civil sevens for the governments.
They pay no income tax,
their energy bills and subsidized and
best salary as well.
Then neutrik Christie,
yeah.
Hi.
Do people who work on oil rigs?
Well,
they're the foreigners,
but this is not only a rihanna see four
key ways it happens all over the region
like goals is allowed to,
all of these countries do enjoy this
way,
right?
The question is,
well,
what happens now,
as you probably know,
the market price for crude oil has
fallen in recent years.
Of course these oil Monica is are still
making profits but not enough to keep
that system going and this is why today
all of these countries have fiscal
deficits.
This means they're spending is way
higher than their income.
Hey
to the chart.
Even the USA I come through,
which is really worried about his
deficits is doing better than these
countries.
I now you might wonder,
what does this figure actually mean?
Well,
this means that if the Kuwaitis don't
want to go bankrupt in just a few years,
they better find some alternative
incomes,
not rely entirely on oil.
Nonetheless,
despite two ways,
having the most to modern and democratic
political system,
they have the highest dependence on
crude oil.
Even Saudi Arabia regressive as they all
is better prepared for a plummet in the
price of oil,
and this is a surprise for everybody
because during the 1970s Kuwait was the
Rockstar of the region.
Now this title goes to Dubai despite it
being an absolute monarchy and this is
left him in.
The Arab is wondering whether democracy
is compatible with economics.
Cool.
Wait,
has stagnated,
frustrating the people of a country once
seen as a Middle East trailblazer,
let's say that you want to start a
logistics company in Dubai.
You just need to buy some land and build
the facilities,
right?
Well,
in Kuwait this is almost impossible.
The government's owns 90% of the
territory.
On the other hand is bureaucracy as
reached insane levels according to the
world about in kids is easy to get to
start a business in countries like
Ukraine or El Salvador than it is in Qa.
Yes,
and all of this is despite the fact that
Kuwait has a lower corporate tax rate of
the Luxembourg added to this,
all these sky high salaries of civil
workers,
which rise year after year,
and you can probably imagine that no one
is going to become an entrepreneur and
to leave behind the comfort and safety
of a government job to even the quiches
and transfer the money outside because
they cannot do business.
They're taught to do the short term,
the short term,
but now all of a sudden the Qatari
crisis has offered Kuwait a chance to
emerge as a regional leader.
Their royal house has good relationships
with all the countries involved,
including the United States,
Saudi Arabia and Qatar plus step
analytical system is the most open and
democratic in the region.
In other words,
they have the best chance of becoming a
mediator in this crisis.
And they're well aware of wait,
Amir to travel to Saudi for Qatar talks.
It's like,
now the question becomes,
do you think Kuwait's can take back its
role as a regional leader?
Can this crisis help them to showcase
that country for foreign investments?
Well,
let us know what you think in the
comment section below.
We're waiting to happen
from you.
Meanwhile,
things are far from quiet in Saudi
Arabia.
They're royal houses having an internal
war to determine who is going to be the
successor of the prince.
Take here if you would like to know more
about that
story.
Of course,
do not forget to visit our friends adds
to the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the voice you had on this
video that is not mine.
And don't forget when publish brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday.
So please do subscribe to this channel
and you witness any of those videos.
And finally,
if you like this video,
please do give it a thumbs up.
And there's always,
I'll see you in the next video.
And if you'd like to hear more of my
lovely voice,
you can join us at reconsider the
podcast that covers politics,
but we don't do the thinking for you
available on your favorite podcatcher.
See you there.